the cranks of Franconia in southern
Germany are a good place to climb
Alexander meggles and his friends train
here regularly Mako's has been rock
climbing since he was five he's one of
the best young climbers in Europe and
was even European Youth champion Mako's
combs the world for exciting new heights
and he says rock climbing is not
dangerous talking into one the anchors
in the rock face are very very firm you
can put your weight on them without any
problem they can take several tons of
load at first sight climbing might look
risky because of the height but if you
look more closely you'll see it's not
dangerous at all rock climbing has
become a popular pastime and is no
longer the preserve of experts the
number of climbers in Germany has
doubled over the past decade it's great
exercise and a challenge you can push
your boundaries and you really get to
know yourself it's wonderful this will
do mind father told us all my there are
many different techniques and in kinds
of grips you don't just take the same
route until it gets boring it's always
demanding and always new and different
membership has been rising fast in the
German Alpine Club the world's biggest
climbers club it has more than a million
members this afternoon rock climbing has
been gaining ground for 20 years now
first slowly and faster in recent years
many more people know about it nowadays
on this female in the earthly katanga
calm sports and exercise are indeed
moving up at least in Germany the
financial crisis of the past few years
has hardly dented sales here in fact
sporting goods manufacturers make
healthy profits big city folks spend
lots on equipment and don't even have to
travel far to use it
that's because climbing walls are
springing up across the country often in
old factory buildings and of course
indoor sport is it affected by the
weather there are already over 400
climbing centers in Germany most of them
are quite new pillow Thank You mizzou
cool I think people are looking for more
extreme experiences in their everyday
lives climbing certainly fits the bill
it's an all-or-nothing sport either you
get to the top r you don't bouldering is
a kind of rock climbing that does
without rope or harnesses the maximum
height is usually less than 10 meters
and it's cheaper bouldering doesn't
require much equipment perhaps just a
pair of shoes connected sisal as opposed
to route climbing bouldering often
involves overhangs deep ones with just a
few scattered holds an sirna clinica
found in balloons on the board of idiots
Yun fragment you start here with your
hands and feet climb up and higher up
you just have the holds climbing used to
be an entirely outdoor sport the views
were all part of the experience you
would only train indoors when the
weather was bad but now it's all
different many people go to artificial
rock faces and halls in town I'll
season-high in some opinions what used
to be training facilities have turned
into real sports centres for indoor
climbing now bouldering is really taking
off climbing has become a sporting
activity in its own right I call these
people fitness climbers funding fitness
collective odd weather on a real rock
face or on an artificial face indoors
climbing remains a sport for
individualists where they each test
their limits
you